today I'll stick to football we're gonna
look at some coaching hot seats in the
NFL college football we've already seen
basically Black Monday with a lot of
coaches on the move and then because it
is Monday Cyber Monday even we're gonna
give you a round one mock draft with all
the changes we've seen with the draft
order being shaken up and then get into
your draft on draft questions but Connor
we got to remind everybody this Saturday
we will be in Atlanta Georgia at the SEC
championship game with Johnsonville
right outside the mercedes-benz stadium
Johnson Bill's huge tailgate we will be
there basically taking over the damn
thing with Sean Alexander's our guest
yeah it's gonna be awesome man we're
excited to get down to Atlanta go to the
SEC Championship obviously there's gonna
be some good football played there as
well but before we get into all that
we'll be right outside mercedes-benz so
if you're around come by say hi we're
gonna be doing a show with our guest
Sean Alexander he might be a little
upset no Alabama shockingly this year
but it's gonna be a really good time and
before we get into our full first-round
mock draft today because it is mock
draft Monday and your draft entre have
questions Matt we got to talk about NFL
coaches on the hot seat and even before
that the hot seats that turn into ash in
college football this past weekend yeah
it was like one after another and some
of those ridiculous some of it was
expected we expected clay Helton to be
fired at USC really something we've been
talking about all season long as that is
the most likely landing spot for Urban
Meyer if he wants to get back into the
coaching game Charlie Strong fired at
South Florida Barry Odom fired at Mizzou
Matt Luke may be the biggest surprise
fire to Ole Miss Steve adagio gone at
Boston College and on top of this you
have Arkansas which was already open you
know Florida State which was already
open so a lot of jobs especially USC in
Florida State that were used to be blue
blood programs and they're gonna look
for guys who can get them back on top
and then in the middle of the country
you have a lot of openings Mizzou
Arkansas Ole Miss and those teams are
really gonna be vying for the same
couple of candidates I think everyone
looks at Memphis and what Mike Norvell
has done there is a really really good
head coach a very good candidate if he
doesn't go to Florida State I think
there's a good chance that he will get
one of those jobs and then Napier at
Louisiana is another one the raging
ages have been so good this year that it
almost feels like Napier is the guy
right behind Norville we're whichever
job Norville takes Napier might take the
other so Missouri Arkansas it's gonna be
fun and my hope is that guys like Lane
Kiffin and Mike Leach get in here and
turn this thing upside down
yeah me too it's kind of interesting
where you know what's next for Michael
Lee she almost feels like one of those
guys where you know everything is really
fun and great for a couple years and
then it might be time to move on to
something else you always say that Matt
is the message getting stale and I'm not
saying Washington state by any stretch
of the means is in a terrible state
right now it's just a matter of is this
one of these one of these jobs a good
one for leech to move to I like that you
bring up Lane Kiffin because with lane
you know he always sits there and says
how much he loves the program he's
building right now but you have to think
in the back of his head Lane wants to
get you know maybe back into the SEC at
some point and even if that's not the
case just onto a bigger job but it has
to be the right job when you look at USC
it feels like they wanted to fire clay
at clay Helton for like 14 straight
months right now and it's just I mean
everything we had heard is when Kliff
Kingsbury took that offensive
coordinator job for a week is that that
would eventually be his head coaching
job in a matter of no time cliff gets
stolen by the NFL and all that plan goes
to [ __ ] USC is gonna be the job that
every national media story is gonna be
written about because of Urban Meyer
because a big big potential coach ties
and I do think the surprising one is
Charlie Strong here a little bit I know
USF has been really bad against teams
with winning records but it's still a
little surprising because you have to
wonder what's the next move for USF I
don't think Charlie did a terrible job
there it just seems like like many
college programs no matter how big or
small you are they have very high
standards yeah I think it's been
interesting you know obviously as a
Texas fan to watch Charlie from where he
was at Louisville where I mean he he was
like a sure thing to get a huge national
job he goes to Texas and you know
immediately tries to turn the program
over getting rid of some of the
entitlement that was there with Mack
Brown and it just feels like Charlie was
kind of set up to fail there and so I
was like okay well he'll go back to his
roots who go back to South Florida where
he can recruit where he can develop and
it just in never
down so I think it's that one is a
really big surprise to me because I
really thought okay Texas is just too
big for Charlie
but he'll he'll bounce back like he'll
land on his feet at a good spot like USF
and then he'll get back to a power five
school so that one is I think one of the
biggest surprises to me and of course
like you said Connor u.s.c and FSU we're
gonna dominate the conversation here I
think a lot of us gonna be will Urban
Meyer leave TV where he has been
exceptional this year will he leave for
one of these head coaching jobs and and
we have to again talk about what is the
trickle-down effect of Alabama not
making the playoffs because those
assistants at Alabama
whether it's Steve Sarkisian or someone
else normally those dudes are gonna be
tied up now for an another five weeks
basically because Alabama is out of the
playoff and they're gonna be preparing
for a bowl game that I don't even know
how many of their players are gonna play
in I think some of those Alabama
assistants are going to be a little more
poachable this year and Nick Saban has
always had to deal with this every year
Alabama loses top assistants but it
feels like this year they might lose
more than normally because of the way
that this system is set up well let's
move to the NFL side of things because
this is also interesting and I sketched
it out this morning
I believe that seven to eight NFL head
coaches could be on the firing block
this line it is a lot so they miss
Washington's already open right
Cincinnati they beat your Jets on Sunday
I don't know how Andy Dalton comes back
off the bench which makes you wonder why
the [ __ ] he was there in the first place
it really does right they be they beat
the Jets to get a win that basically
maybe they are now the the race with
that first pick between them in the New
York Giants is a little tighter but so
the Bengals maybe they keep Zach Taylor
but the Giants Pat Shermer feels like
that dude's gone Washington's already
open Atlanta
feels like Dan Quinn's gone Detroit the
Lions are three eight and one this year
I don't know that we're talking enough
about that because they are just so bad
somebody please Godfrey Matt Stafford
Matt Patricia could be fired Doug
Marrone could be fired in Jacksonville
where it's obvious that Nick Foles is
not the long-term answer that they
expected he would be Adam GaSe should be
fired just for losing yesterday to the
Cincinnati Bengals I mean and then in
their just 14 right now overall Carolina
Carolina's five and seven Vegas
this season but it doesn't look like
they're going to and I think Ron Rivera
you said it earlier one of my
catchphrases the dudes message might be
getting stale Ron Rivera could be fired
it seems like Jason Garrett is done in
Dallas which is crazy because you know
they right now someone has to win the
NFC East and it looks like it will be
them so it is fascinating right now but
there's me seven or eight jobs that are
just the ones that we expect and there's
always a surprise or two so if there's
gonna be a lot of turnover but I know
you wanted to go off a little bit about
the sad state of coaching in New York
right now oh I could start with that I
mean first and foremost what Pat Shermer
if the Giants don't fire him you could
sit there and say this is a rebuilding
Giants team and a lot of that for the
reason the rebuild is taking so long is
a lot of misses by Dave gentlemen but
even when Daniel Jones has a good Drive
and you see guys like Darius slate and
contribute the defense can't stop anyone
but the decision-making from the head
coach is horrendous and it's not getting
better it's getting worse
and this is a franchise that you could
go out and probably get a guy like Matt
rule and that should excite you and you
should not go out and get a guy like
Jason Garrett which has been rumored
with the Giants when you look at the
Jets it just blows my mind
how many times Adam GaSe could take a
step forward and then do a backflip
backwards it is like unreal and fall and
break his neck
it's unreal to watch all of the good
things the Jets did the last three weeks
with Sam's Arnolds which we talked about
a lot on this show how good he's been
they ripped it up and they threw it in
the trash and said we're going back to
this Peyton Manning Denver style offense
this drop him back slow developing plays
long routes an offensive line that can't
block where Carlos Dunlap came into the
game with two and a half sacks he had
three sacks yesterday they didn't roll
Darnell's away from him one time not one
time they didn't help Brandon shale with
him at all it's absolutely insane to
watch this team get away from the fake
screens the rollouts
the misdirection everything that made
the often so good the last three weeks
Adam GaSe said I don't want to do that
anymore I want to do things my way the
way I know things have worked for me in
the past and you lose to a nother
winless team you lost the Owen seven
dolphins you lose
the own 11 Bengals this is past the
point of embarrassment Christopher
Johnson has made and this is saying a
lot because this is really hard to do
Christopher Johnson has made one of the
worst decisions in the history of the
New York Jets and they can either
correct it at the end of the year and
let the GM fire him which I don't care
how good a friend's they are you know
Joe Douglas wants to go find this guy
that's competent or they could say we
don't want to eat the money it's what
you go back to Matt where you always say
when you drive a car off the lot it
loses so much of his value the Jets
drove the Adam GaSe car off the lot
after being convinced by the scumbag
salesman and now they're so scared of
losing that return on investment that
they're probably going to go into next
year with him or saying they are because
they don't want to pay the four-year 30
million-dollar contract for a guy that's
not working for them it's a mess and we
could do this with a lot of these
coaches on this list but it had to start
with the two disasters in New York right
now yeah it does and I think for teams
like we talked about let's look at this
whole picture if there are seven or
eight open jobs let's say for argument's
sake the Jets are one of those teams
even though like you said that ownership
is said Adam GaSe we'll be back and
we'll see what happens in the next four
weeks
but I feel like and this is no
disrespect to the Jets because I love
Sam Donald and love Jamal Adams that
instead of the least attractive jobs
because of ownership and even with Joe
Douglas who I think will be a very good
general manager I think he's assembled a
very good staff as a head coach opening
that's a bad one because of ownership
and you could take that all the way back
to Bill Belichick deciding not to go
there really not just trying to pour
salt in this wound but this has been an
issue for the Jets since Woody Johnson
bought the team is that unstable
ownership makes this a job where you
have to settle for an Adam GaSe when you
have an opening with a 21 year old
franchise quarterback you have to settle
for Adam GaSe so I think that's their
problem right now you know who can they
get they should have hired Matt rule
that's obvious now in hindsight but who
can they get if this job opens back up
and I think if even if you're the Giants
or if you're the the Carolina Panthers
like those are teams that have huge
question marks is Daniel Jones the
future what with the Panthers you
obviously are not gonna bring Cam Newton
back at 19 million dollars a year next
year but Kyle Allen hasn't been great
either
so this aren't a struggle starting to
struggle
some of that is what's around him as
well I mean I again Palin went undrafted
for a reason I had him ranked undrafted
for a reason but you look at these teams
like okay well what did where the good
openings right now and like that's the
hard part is Dallas is a great opening
obviously but they're gonna be very
limited very selective about who comes
in there as a candidate and then after
that you know Carolina's five and seven
they're the next best team right now
that we expect to be open so there's a
lot of really really bad jobs and I
think Cleveland is an interesting one
that I didn't mention earlier but Freddy
kitchens is trash
and awful I think Willie unprepared I
don't really like care about the t-shirt
thing because I get you're trying like
rally your team but I've said this on
this show for months
you're either allowing it or you're
coaching it and I think that's with
Freddy kitchens like why is his team
undisciplined
because he's undisciplined and like this
is one of the most penalized teams in
football you see it every Sunday they're
losing games in new maddening ways and
that trickles down from the head coach
so I think with Cleveland man I wonder
Freddy kitchens to succeed because he's
that he's not part of that good old boys
network like this dude was gonna shake
things up
it just it obviously has not worked
there I'm with you all the way it's
frustrating for the Browns when you come
in with I mean there were Super Bowl
talk but at least playoff expectations
and this is a team where you're sitting
there and you're looking at the schedule
and you go damn like the bills after
their Thanksgiving win quietly one of
the best coach teams in the NFL the
Buffalo Bills you look at their
Thanksgiving win you say alright the
bills are probably locked into that wild
card if New England continues to you
know play like they did on Monday night
on Sunday Night Football that division
might get interesting I don't I'm not
there yet
but you look at that second wild card
spot and you see how Oakland's played
these last couple of weeks horrendous
defense the Browns were in the driver's
seat to make this right and maybe go OK
a couple easy wins here you could sneak
into that wild card
we might not believe in Freddie but at
least the team is playing hard and they
could sneak into a playoff spot and he
give him another year what they're
putting out there right now and she's
not cutting it it's not cutting it for a
Browns team with high expectations and
that's what a lot of the problem with
these teams are Cowboys expectations
should be high that roster is from
nominal Wilma clay has put together a
phenomenal roster there Zach Prescott is
playing at an extremely high level it's
just you look at these jobs the Falcons
have underachieve Jacksonville like you
said they're just spinning in circles
right now I don't know what that
football team is but I do know they
should be a team rallying behind Gardner
Minshew again not Nick Foles a lot of
these jobs will be open and yeah the
rankings for how they'll be are very
different but at the end of the day none
of these coaches we mentioned in the
opening in this show have come even
close to living up to the expectations
that were set for them absolutely not
all right let's take a break we come
back round one of mock draft Monday
we're gonna break down 1 through 32 the
Cincinnati Bengals are on the clock it
is mock draft time the Cincinnati
Bengals are on the clock with that 1 and
11 record and this one is obvious guys I
know chase young is an elite talent he's
a fantastic player but if you don't have
a quarterback you don't have a chance to
win the Bengals have to select Joe
burrow quarterback LSU I love Joe burrow
it's been so much fun watching him play
this year sadly the college football
regular season is over I think we're
gonna see burrow continue to climb
through SEC championship through the
college football playoffs I hope to god
we see this man at the Senior Bowl
because I think he can solidify that qb1
status by going to mobile where the
Bengals are going to be one of the
team's coaching as long as they don't
fire Zach Brown he can be on that squad
all week long with Zach Taylor learning
that scheme building a rapport and make
himself the number one pick in this
draft yeah that's gonna be a lot of fun
for that alone Joe should get down to
the Senior Bowl work with that staff get
an early jump especially how much
limited time teams have with players
before training camp which is really
none besides minicamp although if you
saw the red rifle there Matt on Sunday I
don't know maybe she says he wants to
come back I mean no play somewhere next
year I'll say that much number two the
New York Giants what a perfect position
for them if you're a Giants fan you want
to keep losing lose out the rest of the
way and get chase young second overall
this would be a franchise changing pic
for the New York Giants a defensive end
you remember those 2007 and 2011 Super
Bowl teams I know everyone talks about
Eli Manning those teams were built on
the defensive line and how they got
after Tom Brady they can really go full
circle here and get a guy that could do
that again we chase young I love it
that's such a no-brainer like this is
the boys who is so easy right now right
just don't overthink it one two are very
easy three it gets complicated the
Washington Redskins there's been reports
they might finally fire Bruce Allen they
can't fire Daniel Snyder because he's
the owner but there could be a shake-up
in this football department which means
maybe they consider a quarterback if the
new guy comes in and doesn't love doing
askance we can see a quarterback
considered here but I think this smart
move and this is not ideal is to draft a
cornerback here Jeff Okuda I think the
kut'rs one of the top five players in
the country I think he's the number one
corner by far in this class he would
have been last year he would have been
the year before that for me he is as
close to shutdown as you can get coming
out of college obviously three overall
it's very early for a corner but that's
the way this class breaks there's it's
really a one quarterback class right now
with the uncertainty of Tua's injury
there's not an offensive tackle that I
believe is worth the top five pick the
Redskins get stuck here with Jeff accout
who's a good player in a normal draft
you'd say three overall is not bad for
him the Redskins have bigger needs but
this is the best player who's available
man I love what I've seen from him I
really do it's it's hard to justify
unless they're elite a corner going in
the top five and when you watch a coup
to play
you see elite traits at the position so
I think that would be great what's
interesting with the Redskins Matt and I
have talked about this for a long time
if everyone gets fired there what
happens with Dwayne Haskins that's the
big question that everyone's gonna sit
and watch with them but we have plenty
of time to figure that out number four
the Miami Dolphins didn't expect them to
be picking here but the good news is the
guy they wanted all along is probably
gonna be on the board and that's to a
tongue of Eylau a--
there are a lot of questions about to
her right now will he make the full
recovery a lot of people will tell you
he will can you trust him holding up
long-term with the injuries those things
will be sorted out towards the NFL
Combine but right now the Dolphins need
a quarterback because Ryan Fitzpatrick
of course is doing exactly what we
expected and winning them too many games
to be picking in time for the top guy
and I still think tiwa is more than
talented enough where you take this risk
at pick number four yeah I think so
and again right now we're speculating it
really depends on what's gonna what's
going look like two months what's going
like in three
months now as we say here at three
months away from the NFL Scouting
Combine so a lot of questions will be
answered in Indianapolis number five the
Atlanta Falcons would love Jeff cooter
here obviously we fixed this team on
last week's podcast
I'm gonna go Derek Brown an amazing
interior presence he plays all over for
that Auburn defense you see him stand up
in rush at times he plays some defensive
and he plays some defensive tackle put
this man on the line with Grady Jarrett
and you're gonna solve a lot of problems
a lot of problems solved it for the
Atlanta Falcons to Kayla McGarry got
absolutely worked by Cameron Jordan the
other night so maybe offensive lines in
consideration here but I think Derek
Brown makes a lot of sense for them yeah
not a tape that Caleb McGarry is gonna
want to relive I'll say that much but
Derek Brown there might not be a more
dominant player in the country right now
besides chase young number six the
Detroit Lions for whatever reason they
took a tight end over a Tolliver last
year I have no explanation why but they
will not make that mistake this year if
we're in control AJ epinet at number six
I've had some really good conversations
with a lot of different people on
Twitter I know that seems taboo to say
but about epinet where he's six six he's
280 he's probably gonna continue to get
bigger stronger he might really be an
interior player at the next level if you
watch both his sacks this weekend they
were against interior offensive lineman
so I like the versatility he can bring
to a Lions front that needs help
I don't think Matt Patricia is gonna be
coaching there next year whether he is
or isn't this is the right pick for
Detroit in the top ten
I love AJ up in essa and I feel like
this year he's been a little
disrespected because people just want
stats like this you stuck with them I
did stick with him yeah and like
everyone's like where's his production
well it actually came on and I I would
love to find the show where I said this
like just wait until we get into Big Ten
play a lot of the think teams they're
seeing right now everything they're
doing is to get away from him so epinet
I absolutely love him at 6 overall I
think he's actually a good value number
seven the Arizona Cardinals Jerry Judy
comes off the board here I still think
Judy's one of the three or four best
players in this class I am a little
concerned about some of the just body
drops that we've seen from him over the
last two weeks LSU and Auburn especially
like in those games like come on like
you're better than this what are you
doing his route running his burst his
agility his foot
work he's still the best receiver in
this class in my opinion the Cardinals
need a true number-one wideout with
Larry Fitzgerald in close to retirement
Christian Kirk's a good complementary
guy but I don't believe he's a true
number one so as much as I would love a
left tackle here I think that's a huge
need for them we've said it before we
don't know how much
Kliff Kingsbury he's gonna value
offensive linemen early in the draft
we know he values receivers after
watching last year's draft so Jerry Judy
a really really good fit and value here
I absolutely love that pick I think Judy
would be one of the most high-profile
fantasy rookies we've seen in quite some
time if that was his landing spot number
eight Jacksonville Jaguars we had one of
our listeners on Twitter this weekend go
why do you guys never give my Jaguars
Isaiah Simmons and I'm sorry I don't
have their name pulled up right now but
when me and Matt sat down to do this
mock draft before the show this morning
I was looking and I get to pick number
eight I'm picking for Jacksonville and
of course the best guy available for
them is Isaiah Simmons so there you are
they get Isaiah Simmons he had a
phenomenal week against South Carolina
he's just a great player you watch the
speed you watch the coverage the Blitz
ability to run defense he really does it
all he plays with a really high motor
for a guy with his talent I think
Jacksonville is gonna be a lot of
questions about the direction of this
team going forward but I'll tell you
what if you can get a guy like Simmons
at the 8th overall pick that's a
defensive piece you have to feel really
good about and you still have another
first-round pick in this draft yeah what
tell Ben Smith's future so uncertain
this is a really smart pick for them
they need playmakers defensively another
team that we could see maybe go
quarterback but it seems like with what
they've done with signing Nick Foles
with Gardner Minshew showing some
capability they probably wouldn't go
there in round one number nine your New
York Jets it has to be left tackle here
and I'm gonna Andrew Thomas I know like
CD land will look great here I think
Henry rugs a hell of a playmaker any
other some pass rushers that you would
consider but I think Andrew Thomas is I
know I've been a little hard on him I
still believe he's a top 15 player in
this class at number 9 overall maybe
this is a tiny bit of a reach but the
premium of this position and the
gigantic need to build a good offensive
line around Sam dartle makes Andrew
Thomas it close to just a no-brainer
pick as we get into this time of year as
the draft order starts to solidify
they're gonna be picks where do you guys
gonna hear him a lot from us you're
probably gonna get tired of them but
sometimes they just make so much
from a scheme fit of value and need and
I think Andrew Thomas to the Jets is one
of those picks yeah I think Jets fans
alike that because whenever I don't take
offensive linemen they don't want to
hear it so I like Andrew Thomas and I
think it would really help the run game
alright number ten the Los Angeles
chargers listen we did a long bid on it
last week or two weeks ago this is a
team that needs to start looking at the
future a quarterback we are not very
high each of us on Justin Herbert right
now but the NFL will be high on Justin
Herbert and this is the kind of landing
spot where I can sell it because he
doesn't have to go into next season as
the starter Tyrod Taylor can be your
starter next year Phillip Rivers walks
away you can develop Justin Herbert get
him right for that system playing with
the Chargers it's not the same
quarterback spotlight that it is with
the Browns the Jets all of these other
places the Cowboys where every time you
throw an incompletion there's a story
about it I don't see it like that with
the Chargers this is a good landing spot
for Herbert at number 10 it really is I
think he needs somewhere like this to
where he's not going to be put under the
spotlight of we talked about with Sam
d'Arnaud last week oh my god you went
out in New York
and it's you know it's a page six
article I think this is what the type of
atmosphere that Herbert needs and we'll
see what what happens there there's been
a bad year in there been reports they
might even bench Phillip Rivers so it's
crazy to watch number 11 the Denver
Broncos drew Lough gets his first win
and his first start Congrats to Drew
they need to help him up front and I
think we can all say that Garrett Bowles
was not a great pick by them they could
look at corner here obviously with Chris
Harris jr. about to walk but I think
when you can get an offensive tackle you
have to do it
Tristan wharfs is like the anti Garrett
bulls he's not a flashy athlete he's
just incredibly solid and his hand
placement his technique his power could
play either left or right tackle which I
think is very important so I like
Tristan works here too the Denver
Broncos all right next up the
Philadelphia Eagles this is a surprise
man then picking at number 12 is not
something that we saw coming here they
lost to the Dolphins this weekend and I
don't think that secondary can cover
anyone right now the Eagles have some
health problems there's just not a
corner I love for them this early in the
draft and I can't pass on CD lamb here I
think if you want Carson Wentz to be
playing at an MVP
level again you're not gonna go in next
year where guys like Nelson Aguilar are
getting targets they have a great tight
end doing sacker it's in Dallas Cotter I
don't know what the future of Alshon
Jeffrey is there I love Myles Sanders
they have a good offensive line if you
can get that number one wide receiver
you can really get out into a shootout
with anyone and CD lamb is that kind of
dude yeah he absolutely is and they
draft him for the future last year
taking andre tiller in the first round
to be the left tackle the future they
just signed Lane Johnson to an extension
so you have to feel good about where
they're at and I agree I give them a
receiver almost every time CD lamb or
Henry rugs they need reliability at the
pass catcher position they don't have it
right now number 13 the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers we rag down this team for a
long time for not taking during James
they can fix that by taking grant Talpa
who I thought grant played his best game
of the year on Saturday I really showed
up I know it's Texas A&M but man he was
flying around the ball and my suspicion
all year has been Delpit is holding back
because he doesn't want to get hurt or
he's buying into the hype a little bit
it seemed like on Saturday he remembered
like oh [ __ ] I need to play well or I'm
gonna fall down on the draft I love
Grant Delta in this defense
Connor you know it well Todd Bowles
could use a guy like Grant Delpit and
that jamal adams roll and play near the
line of scrimmage let it blitz off the
corner just find different mismatches
for him to go be a difference maker on
defense so I think Delpit this is one of
those best scheme fits that I found
without a doubt Todd Bowles can get the
most out of defensive backs especially
versatile guys like Delpit that could
play at the line of scrimmage and also
cover when you need them to 14 the
Carolina Panthers this is one of the
bigger risers in the draft and if you
watched Jonah Williams last year you saw
this other bully on the right side
that's Jedrek wills at Alabama I look at
the Panthers I was the first say I
didn't like the Greg little pick next
year last year I don't know if it'll
work out but I know this is a team that
still needs help on the offensive line
this is a team that quarterback is gonna
be very interesting for the next couple
of years and when you look at it they
have the best running back in football
and Christian McCaffrey
Jedrek wills is a guy that you could
stick it right tackle he probably could
play a little left tackle and let's be
real you could run behind him all day
yeah I really like this landing spot
with Carolina wills is interesting to me
because it said we've seen him play
right tackle and he's been surrounded by
really really good players you know even
Alex Leatherwood plan beside him last
year he is someone that I'm ain't
just to try to this type of year this
time here it's hard to like get the cut
out of I just want to watch him and pass
protection
I can't wait to spotlight him and see
how he looks as a mover and pass
protection because I think he could
either like you said push up this year
or should he come out I can see him fall
down the board a little bit just based
on movement purely numbers you hit him
in Louisville offensive lineman yeah
Becton those are the two guys that
everybody's gonna have their eyes on
their past Pro to see if they're round
one players yeah and I I would say I
would even put leather wood in there the
the other tackle if he decides to come
out which probably will because it's
Alabama I think he is an interesting
dude to evaluate as well alright number
fifteen the Cleveland Browns a lot of
needs on this roster that we did not
expect there them to have and I think
some of it is health-related obviously
the offensive lines a huge need but
Connor just took jet Aquila I do not
feel comfortable taking and Alex
Leatherwood here or in Austin Jackson
this highly so maybe the Browns are a
trade down candidate should the board
fall this way but they also need help in
the middle of the defense especially if
Joe Schobert leaves as a free agent
Kenneth Murray from Oklahoma I feel like
is that type of player a guy who he can
rush the quarterback a little bit he's
excellent and coverage whether that's
the zone drop we're matching up in man
situations to get tight ends if Schobert
leaves I think middle linebacker is a
gigantic need for the Cleveland Browns
even though they've thrown some draft
picks at this position I don't think
anyone that they have is ready to step
into that role
yeah Murray's like the less freaky
Isaiah Simmons where you actually know
hey he's a linebacker you don't put him
anywhere 16 the Raiders
I mean they need secondary how good lord
do they need it Christian full and when
healthy Fulton is on his a-game
he really is there's no there's only one
Jeff Okuda in this class but when you
get into the next to your corners I love
what Fulton can do I still look at
Oakland and I'll never be a Derek Carr
guy it's really hard for me but they got
a lot of problems outside of just Derek
Carr and that starts at the cornerback
position and the great thing for the
Raiders is they have a lot of draft
capital in the strap they can keep
stacking the deck with young talent yeah
they absolutely can the Raiders are in a
another team in a fun spot you can see
the build happening and it's gonna be
exciting to see where mike Mayock goes
after a really good draft last year I
stayed
we come back we're gonna get through the
second half of round one number 17 the
Indianapolis Colts Chris Ballard has
some work to do and I will say this I am
a Jacoby bris of fan I think he's a
solid quarterback we said it when he got
elevated to this job that and when
Andrew Luck retired he can be good
enough if you have a good defense and
you have playmakers well they had do not
have playmakers that receiver Parish
Campbell hasn't hit yet t Y Hilton's
been banged up they they need help and a
lot of different spots so I think they
are poised to maybe go best player
available but one thing that hasn't
worked for them is what they have in the
secondary right now and I feel like
defensively they need playmakers they
need guys who can flip the field to help
out Jacoby bris to help out Marlon Mack
so I'm gonna go see J Henderson here
over Henry rug's who I feel like would
be a little bit repetitive a little bit
redundant to what they have a Parris
Campbell over Devon to Smith over
Levesque is Shane all I really feel like
CJ Henderson I know we talked to him
last week there you know there's a good
conversation about his stock he could be
the second corner off the board in this
draft where he could be the fifth corner
off the board in this draft so the Colts
I mean maybe they look at someone like
Paulson and D bow instead but I think
Corner is a huge need for them I still
like CJ Henderson I'm excited to see
where the draft process kind of takes
him with him as we dig into more of the
more the tape and more of the
personality with him 18 the Raiders are
back on the clock thanks to the lovely
Chicago Bears selection here and I'm
gonna get at them a receiver this time
two picks ago when Corner got Christian
full and this might surprise you I know
we've had a Henry Rose there but I
actually like the fit a little better
with Devon Smith here I think when you
look at some it's game he's still a
speedster he's still gonna run sub for
four but he's a little more sure-handed
he's a little tougher across the middle
and if they're gonna ride this thing out
with their car and they're gonna be a
punch you in the face kind of offense
with Josh Jacobson the run game I
actually really like the fit of what
Smith can bring to the table just a
little bit more of a rounded game than
drugs right now here for the Raiders
that definitely have to be in the round
one wide receiver market yep they have
to be the losing Antonio Brown I think
you know at times year they've played
really well and you can see like okay
they're their pieces here but man they
still need some more help the Tennessee
Titans at 19 overall I think Ryan
Tannehill is played well enough this
year to maybe get a bridge deal one to
two year where we can see what he
can be and man it's amazing like I I
think Miami just ruined this guy you
know he's playing really wet I'm gay
right there you go I don't wanna say it
I don't want to trigger you I think
there's three and one since he took over
the starting job including beating
Kansas City the run game is taking off
their what they need though I love AJ
Brown he was my number one receiver in
the draft last year and rookie wide
receivers unless you're Michael Thomas
it takes a second tackle mate so we're
not giving up on him
we want to give him some help that's
where Henry rug's comes in and I know
this might seem like a luxury pick for
the Titans but when you're at this spot
in the draft at 19 I'm looking for
playmakers you're not gonna draft a
quarterback here you're probably not
gonna defensively they've thrown a lot
of picks at guys Jeffrey Simmons has
been amazing so I want to find someone
on offense who can maybe help set this
team over the top for me that's Henry
rugs now something interesting though to
keep an eye on Derrick Henry's free
agent and he's been amazing the last
three or four games and he's really been
good the last 16 games he's been really
really good I'm gonna be interested to
see how they value Derrick Henry that
big body that takes a lot of hits where
they value him moving forward because
this could be a sleepy spot for guy like
John Dre Swift out of Georgia yeah I'm
with you all the way I love that point
you make about wide receivers it's
ridiculous what guys like Michael Thomas
and Mike Evans have done just thousand
yards year after year after year from
the get-go
all right 20 the Jaguars back on the
clock for them again got Isaiah Simmons
earlier now it's time to take a look at
this offensive line get Gardner Minshew
the future down there some help I went
with Trey Adams once again a medical
kind of player he's had a lot of
surgeries in the past but he's looked
great this year for Washington he's
great run blocker he's got the perfect
frame and lane for pass protection
really loved what I saw out of him in
person against USC and really have loved
the film this year I think trey is one
of those guys as long as he's healthy
he's a difference maker at right tackle
left tackle wherever you want to put him
in Matt you said it when we do a lot of
these mock traps the Jaguars are gonna
be looking to retool this group in the
trenches a little bit yeah they're gonna
have to you know cam Robinson's not
getting it done at left tackle and I
think with Trey Adams the biggest
question mark is health you know missing
the 2018 season with a back injury where
is he at in terms of health you know
what are we looking at how is he gonna
hold up long term some of the
that I've seen this year how much of
that can be attributed to missing last
year how much of it is attributed to
where he's just maybe limited a little
bit post-injury so he is a guy we better
see at the Senior Bowl because he needs
that week you could really improve his
stock number 21 the Dallas Cowboys Javon
kianlawl is my guy here they're gonna
lose Byron Jones to free-agency a corner
so maybe they would draft someone there
but Javon can lull to fall this far is
it a little bit of a surprise I think he
could be a top he's the top 12 pick I
wouldn't be shocked
so put Kinlaw in the middle of this d
line where they haven't had a great
return yet on last year's second rounder
on the D line so I think looking at it
like okay we like Tristan Hill he could
be a good player but I really feel like
next to Malik Collins or in a three-man
rotation Siobhan Killa will be their
best defensive tackle pretty much
immediately get him on this D line where
we don't know who's gonna be coaching it
next year because everything's up in the
air in Dallas right now I think King
Louis is too good of a value to pass
he's an absolute beast and it would be
such a good landing spot there in Dallas
but man they're either gonna have to
cross their fingers that him or grant
Delpit false of them it's gonna be real
interesting for Dallas 22 we get we
start our back-to-back dolphins picks
here this one is from the Steelers I'm
gonna wet your gross Tomatoes this is a
team that needs some edge pass rush it's
been fun to watch taco Charlton kind of
reignite his career under Brian Flores a
believe he has five sacks chanson
acquaintance man Wayne it really is
because I didn't even really love him at
Michigan so when it didn't work out in
Dallas I shrugged my shoulders like yeah
wasn't a first round player Miami
getting a lot of value out of him but
you got to keeps your not gonna rely on
him next year keep stacking the deck
gross tomatoes is a very good
well-rounded player a very high
character player he is a classic New
England but Brian Flores kind of player
for that defensive line oh yeah
absolutely and they're right back on the
clock actually because of that trade
with Houston 23 overall we've given them
a quarterback into a pass rusher gross
tomatoes now they need a receiver how
many of them T Higgins I've said before
I've tweeted a lot about it t Higgins is
somehow being slept on as is the entire
Clemson Tigers offense right now I still
like T Higgins I will be interested to
see where he tests what do you waste I
think there's one of the biggest
question marks is he 200 is it 215
where's that body at but we've seen it
at times
this man can still get loose deep he can
make plays adjusting his body on the
ball I'm a big t Higgins believer and I
think the Miami Dolphins need help in
the passing game yes I would love a left
tackle here
don't get me wrong guys yes that would
be a great spot but I don't have a left
tackle on my board that I would pick
here at 23
yeah those seven touchdowns in the last
four games have been awesome forty stock
and he's gonna have a huge opportunity
in the college football playoff he
really can he could pass some of the
guys that will not be given the
opportunity to play in an ad wide
receiver like the Alabama guys
potentially CD lambs you know all those
players so t Higgins the stock might be
climbing right back up there 20 for the
Minnesota Vikings got to go corner here
exhibit Xavier Rhodes has fallen apart
this year I talked about falling off a
cliff and he's not even 30 yet Jeff
Gladney we've had him at the top of the
second round I still think that's his
projected range but listen this team
needs a corner and Gladney can be a very
very good starter right away he's
somebody that went back to school for a
senior year at TCU has played very well
he's light but he has good length and I
think Minnesota they need help in that
secondary yeah they really do and I
think Gladney is interesting the guy I'm
gonna give the Kansas City Chiefs here
at number 25 overall would be
interesting as well that's Paulson Addie
Bo and I was at the Chiefs Raiders game
huge win top four coldest I've ever been
in my life but she's waiting for Kansas
City and you look at this team it's like
okay well like Dylan Moses would make
some sense here or you know we could go
Trey Smith or Tyler by a dish like
someone in the middle of that offensive
line but what this team really needs a
corner Kendall Fuller who missed like
eight weeks with a finger injury which I
want to slam my head on the desk every
time I think about that fact he's going
to be a free agent and let's be honest
he hasn't played that well since coming
over from Washington I really like what
they have in Ward a young corner that no
one saw coming but they need more help
especially if you're going to keep up
with the Ravens the Patriots what we're
seeing in Buffalo even you're gonna need
playmakers on defense I think Paul Sneed
Deebo with his size his ability to track
the ball down the field even if it's not
interceptions passes defensed the Chiefs
really miss a guy like Marcus Peters
right now I know that's taboo to say
especially in this part of the country
but they do and Paul Senna Deebo can
give them that presence again on defense
you
it was just a pointing we didn't get to
see a debo play when we went out to
Stanford but still believe in his back
end around one talent for sure and
that's the ideal landing spot 26 the
Buffalo Bills another team that needs
wide receiver but so many of the good
ones that we constantly talk about are
gone none of the Alabama guys no T
Higgins they're gone already no cd lamb
here's one and I saw you say it over the
weekend Matt that he could find his way
into round one
it's Donovan peoples Jones this is a
former five-star recruit he's a great
player he's a monster in the red zone he
could play special teams he's a big
bodied go up and get it which is what
Josh Allen needs right now the
quarterback situation in Michigan has
simply held him back yes but if you put
people's Jones on Oklahoma on Clemson on
Alabama on LSU he probably had 1,400
yards and 10 touchdowns I honestly
believe that I really really do and
that's why people's Jones for a team
like the bills that need a big body pass
catcher he might find his way into that
first round I think he will I think
he'll test so well and he'll interview
well John the roof yeah and a good shape
Patterson has ruined this entire team I
really had treat black Nikko Collins
three years ago we were talking about
this is the best receiving trio in the
country and they have not been able to
win games or produce offensively because
Shea Patterson sucks so bad as a
quarterback and like even Ronnie bill
this year they have four receivers who
should probably be top 50 picks just to
be honest and they can't can't move the
ball so Thank You Shea Patterson for
ruining dynamic people's Jones up next
on the clock another receiver coming up
here 27 the Green Bay Packers
I would love a tight end here and I
think you have to consider defense as
well but I'm gonna go offense let's give
Aaron Rodgers some help we saw this
against the 49ers we saw it yesterday as
well they need help or not yeah shakes
to me last week they need help
offensively and I think ylvis' Gachet
know is that guy he's like a young
Randall Cobb but a little bit bigger
where you can put him offensively what
you can ask him to do in this offense
whether it's jet sweeps running the ball
out of the backfield returning kicks and
punts making plays just split out as an
X or Y receiver I still like Shane oh I
think he is going to be somewhat scheme
specific in terms of where he fits
and what he can be asked to do but I've
compared him to Percy Harvin I think the
Packers can use a guy like that
offensively yeah I'm with you there I
think he'd be a lot of fun to watch in
Green Bay get creative with how you use
him because he could do a lot of
different things and he turns into a
running back with the ball in his hands
28 Seattle Seahawks I go Trey Smith here
this is a player that has great
experience at tackle he's been a
phenomenal at guard once again another
you know medical spending kind of
offensive lineman but round 1 talent and
for Seattle if you want to run the ball
and you want a versatile offensive
lineman that you could plug in at four
different positions at Ray Smith is the
guy I mean he blows people off the snap
love what I've seen from him this year
the a spent a great year for Tennessee
but there's been certain promising
things that you see whether it's
Jennings that wide receiver Smith on
that offensive line to get the run game
going if he does declare which is very
up in the air he's gonna be one of the
more polarizing prospects in this draft
yeah like we were said with Trey Adams
medicals will matter a lot what we see
here and this is a Tennessee team or
seven or five like they're as good as
Texas this year let's chew on that for a
little bit I'm gonna cry myself to sleep
this tonight number 29 the New England
Patriots we've seen Tom Brady getting
frustrated with this whether it's the
receivers the tight ends the lack of
playmakers I think some of their
problems offensively go back to an
offensive line that is very banged up
right now I'm gonna try to help them by
giving them a tight end and Bryson
Hopkins he is my number one tight end in
this class he's big bodied you could go
up and get the ball he gonna help in the
run game now the thing with this is and
we've seen it even with TJ Hawkinson
this year it's hard for rookie Titans to
contribute and I think that's where you
with the Patriots like okay I would love
to build this team for the future and
plug holes but how much longer will Tom
Brady be here how open is this window to
where maybe you would rather go defense
and try to plug some of the holes there
with a Raekwon Davis or a Curtis Weaver
or even a Xavier McKinney at safety so
the Patriots draft philosophy is gonna
be really interesting because do they
start to try to turn this roster over
for the future or do they try to plug
some of these holes for one or two more
years yeah I'm with you the Patriots are
such an interesting spot it's weird to
sit there and look at a two loss team
and the sky is falling but there is a
weird sense around them
the sky is falling I don't know they're
gonna be they're gonna be a really
interesting offseason discussion number
30 the Saints we keep giving them
linebackers Dylan Moses here as long as
medically he checks out that he is fully
rehabilitated and back to form after
tearing his knee this summer Moses's a
really good player Demario davis has
been an incredible free agent signing
for the Saints he is getting up there an
age they could use more bodies in the
front seven Moses is almost like a
luxury pick but the Saints are in a
position where they can make one yeah
they really are and again another team
that will see what happens the
quarterback because of Teddy Bridgewater
comes back your print out draft England
if he goes to a bigger free agent
starting quarterback deal then this
could be a spot where you maybe you look
at jaylen Hurst maybe look at Jacob
Eason maybe you're willing to bet on the
traits of a Jordan love personally I
wouldn't be but I think it's something
they have to look at number 31 the
Baltimore Ravens look unbeatable right
now so let's just make them a little bit
better and give them Curtis Weaver I
believe Curtis is a round one pass
rusher coming out of Boise State he has
size he has speed uses hands really
really well it's not the biggest need
for Baltimore I think middle linebacker
would be bigger but like you just take
until the Moses off the board here for
me I have to go to the outside where
they're gonna keep trying to add Talent
some of those last Ozzie Newsome picks
didn't hit and here's a funny story I
almost put Caleb on chase on here from
LSU but Ozzie Newsome as general manager
never drafted a player from LSU and I
don't know that Eric de castas gonna
break that streak now that he's the
general manager man I don't think he
will it's a weird thing but when you're
as good as Baltimore [ __ ] it you can do
it everywhere so 32 your 49ers currently
sitting here in this wonderful 32nd pick
Xavier McKinney the tackling machine now
I know everybody will think of the most
recent memory of him as this helmet
lying off against Auburn that's not fair
he's had a phenomenal season I know
there are a lot of people out there that
are wondering who's gonna be the first
safety off the board is it him or grants
help it McKinney's had the better season
I still believe in Dell Pitts talent but
at this point for the 49ers I asked Matt
before the show I said ma'am what does
this team need because I would love to
take the honorary Swift here they ain't
doing that they don't take running backs
in the first round that is not the
Shanahan way or anyone from the
and tree and they do need some help it's
safety as you said Matt I really like
what we've seen from McKinney this year
yeah absolutely all right let's take a
break we come back we have four awesome
draft on draft questions to get to draft
on draft on McGarrett Greenlee it's like
he was watching us record the show today
he asked we finally admit that Tom Brady
is losing to Father time from 2016 to 19
his completion percentage just gone from
67 to 61 his passer rating from 112 to
88 and he misses throws he would have
made a few years ago is it time for
mellows guy Jarret Stidham in 2020 ah
alright first I'm I'm never gonna be the
guy to say Brady's done right because
then they win the Super Bowl that's how
this goes every year now to speak to the
completion percentage and more
importantly you know the yards per
attempt because I think what's
interesting what Brady is he's he is
turning into a little bit of a dinking
dunk kind of guy and what I know people
say well Brady has always been that
short to intermediate guy you're really
seeing that number drop he doesn't have
Gronk this year and Josh Gordon's gone
and Dorsett's been hurt Edelman got
doubled on Sunday Night Football which
was brilliant by Houston they doubled
Edelman I mean you're relying on Nikhil
Harry who's not great at separating
especially as a rookie right now father
time gets everyone and it will get Tom
Brady I don't know if it's over I don't
think it is first off I think a lot of
it is the offense around him they've had
injuries on the offensive line they
don't have a great group of skilled guys
but to say he won't be the guy in 2020
right now I'm just not there yet I'm not
there yet
I'm not either I love our guy Garrett I
feel like this is a little bit
misleading these stats because last year
Brady completed 65.8% so his completion
percentage was only down half a percent
from 2017 2018 excuse me 2018 and even
what we saw last year 29 touchdowns I
mean he was still good last year and I'm
not a huge quarterback rating guy I
think that's kind of a [ __ ] stat
this year yeah it like you said the
yards per attempt are weighed down and
that's the key but I think it's because
they've had to dink and Duncan Nikhil
Harry being hurt I think
changed this offense a lot Antonio Brown
not working out Josh Gordon not working
out grok retiring and it's tough when
you're drafting constantly at 32 overall
to be able to get high-impact players
you know you're not able you can't get
just will drive TJ Hawkinson plug him in
boom we're done it's a lot harder for
New England so I don't and I'm a brady
guy everyone knows that but I don't want
to assign this year and be like [ __ ]
Brady's done this doesn't look like
Peyton Manning at the end it doesn't
even look like Eli Manning you know or
Joe Flacco where you can just see they
don't have it anymore I think we're
seeing that with Phillip Rivers like if
you want to talk about a player falling
off let's talk about Phillip Rivers and
so I think what Brady
it's more that he doesn't have around
him what we're used to seeing because
like you said no grok teams are just
doubling up Edelman and they can't run
the ball because some of those injuries
upfront I I mean I know they didn't look
good against Houston they lost a
Baltimore they could still win the
Superbowl let's let's not get crazy here
all right Dakota Cox all right wants to
know are there any juniors for Alabama
you see surprising everyone a coming
back for a senior year like Raekwon
Davis or Damien Harris did so I think
this is an interesting question because
we're gonna wait to see college football
playoffs Alabama for the first time not
in it so I think we're gonna be
interested to see number one which
players sit out that game and then like
he asked you which players are going to
come back for another season no one
jumps off the page to me ask the guys
like okay yep he'll come back it just it
doesn't make a lot of sense for some of
them Nagi Harris graduates in December
he's not gonna come back like Damien
Harris did Dylan Moses might be an
interesting one just because of the
injury situation this year but I think
you can look at Raekwon Davis who opted
to go back I don't think it helped him
to go back I still think he's gonna be
probably drafted in the 50 to 65 range
he's not a top 15 player he would have
been a second rounder most likely in
last year's draft you give me a second
render most likely in this year's draft
so I think agents will get to Alabama
which is this is a little bit of an
older Alabama team because of guys like
Raekwon going back but I don't think
anyone's gonna talk you know Alex
Leatherwood or I think wills went back
even that wouldn't be the biggest
surprise but there's just like Jerry
Judy's not going back to Alabama that's
why the only one reroutes
Rose
going back they're not going back there
was a time where because Nagi such a
different kind of dude he's a little bit
more reserved laid-back where I don't
think he'd be he's not dying for the NFL
life is what I'm saying right now she
wanted to go to Alabama to win and
that's why when he didn't start as a
freshman he was so upset right away but
he's been so good this year right I mean
he's been round one good at running back
where you sit there and you say I I hope
he doesn't go back and you should always
do what makes you happy but with the
amount of running back injuries and the
fact that Nagi should be a surefire top
50 pick at running back I can't see that
one happening it would it would really
surprise me but Alabama yeah what do you
got to worry about you restock and
reload every single year and like Riley
Lovelace oh go ahead man like McKinney's
a junior he's probably gonna come out I
think tomorrow myth I've talked to you
about Alabama and they were like we
really hope Devon said it wouldn't go
off this year because we wanted to hide
him for next year we didn't waddle what
you still have Jenna Waddell coming back
you guys gonna be just fine gosh all
right Riley Lovelace will should david
johnson be on another team next year
since Kliff Kingsbury really isn't using
him I think that's just I feel like
David Johnson honestly is kind of at the
end of his run and so if he goes
anywhere I mean he's 27 years old he's
been incredibly banged up he's under
contract for two more seasons oh and
next year the dead cap is 16.2 run what
I was reacting to right if you run into
next year like if you cut this guy like
he's gonna be [ __ ] expensive so I I
mean I god I guess you could try to
trade him no one's taking that money no
nope so you're kind of stuck with him
man what a fall for him I don't rise how
bad it is this year it has like I'm ugly
I get to watch like besides the coaches
snow because I like to watch Kyler but I
got forgot he existed yeah and I think a
lot of people will look at this and say
well Kliff Kingsbury doesn't use a
running back but he does cliff would
love to run the ball as much as anyone
else neon FL I mean that that's this
isn't Texas Tech where he wants to throw
the ball 60 times I think he understands
how important the run game
is and we've even seen I mean they bring
in Kenyan Drake and yes yeah success
that first week but yeah man this is the
number one paid running back in the NFL
I mean Kenyan Drake is like touching
around 20 looks a game yeah that's a lot
it's it kind of gives you the writing on
the wall but they're stuck with that
money last one here for draft on draft
from dust and Lackey if LSU beats
Georgia in the SEC title game
do you see Utah having any chance if
they win the pac-12 or will it go to the
winner of Oklahoma verse Baylor I know
we love this question so much so he gets
to talk about it every week I and I know
they had page on last week she talked a
lot about the eye test of the college
football playoffs because this is a
committee it's not a computer so if LSU
beats Georgia
I don't think Utah has a chance I truly
don't I think it would be Oklahoma and
I'm okay with that I mean it like I was
asking you guys if Oklahoma and Utah
played neutral site right now who wins
that game I would pick Oklahoma and I
think most people would so that's what
the committee's gonna do the same thing
of okay
this is not you know we could pick
whatever four teams we want basically
and I think that the nation will want to
see Oklahoma they'll want to see Lincoln
Riley the one I see Jalen Hertz and CD
lamb
Kenneth Murray no disrespect to Utah is
gonna have like 12 guys at the Senior
Bowl and Tyler Huntley's put it been a
hell of a quarterback for them this year
we love Zach most that defense is loaded
but they're just that's not a sexy team
if it's Utah against LSU in the first
Cosmo ball playoff game or Oklahoma
versus LSU come on like they're trying
to make money it's gonna be Oklahoma
yeah my heart says Utah my head says the
winner of Oklahoma Baylor you know
obviously a lot of people betting on
Oklahoma being that team I still like my
Baylor Bears but anyway I think when you
look at it it's a tough sell and that's
not me and Matt saying that it's a tough
sell for the NC double-a in the gray tee
and how they look at this and if you go
back and remember when you tell us the
USC we were like [ __ ] yeah because we
thought Utah had the path for the pac-12
to finally make an appearance where it's
a go they didn't eat each other apart
this year but they did yeah and that
loss to USC
we just like working probably beat you
tall anyway you know because this is
yeah it would be the most pac-12 thing
ever oh it's never just gonna be a like
Clemson you can say what you want about
Clemson they take care of business
against the shitty ass ACC like they
take care of it and like I want the AC
the ACC to be good but right now it's
not and Clemson ran through it and you
look at Utah in the pac-12 they should
have ran through it and they came really
close but I'd love to I would be the
first one to be happy if they made it in
I just don't see it happening I agree I
again as long as Oklahoma beats Baylor I
think they're in so if LSU beats Georgia
Georgia wins well then Georgia and LSU
get in so things get things get a little
wild out there in the college football
playoff land alright that is our show we
will be back tomorrow my goodness right
yeah we'll be back Wednesday look at a
drag stop we need a team to fix so tweet
us those teams who should we be taking
down this week of college Matt we'll
talk to y'all real soon